الاف المتطوعين الاجانب وصلوا الى
اوكرانيا بطلب من الرئيس زيلينسكي اعدادهم
تراوحت بين 20 و70 الفا الا ان 1500 مقاتل
فقط لا زالوا في اوكرانيا الكثير من
المتطوعين يمتلكون خبره فعليا اما البقيه
فاستغلوا فرصه المشاركه في حرب حقيقيه
فساد وخيانه واختلاس لاموال التبرعات
وبعضهم لا يمتلك اي خبره عسكريه صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز اطلعت على 100 حاله مماثله
ونشرت تفاصيل بعض الحالات
ادعى مشاركته في حرب الخليج وغزو العراق
البنتاجون اكد ان فاسكاز لا يمتلك اي خبره
عسكريه كما انه نشر مواقع كتيبته بدقه عبر
الانترنت ويليام
دليل سياحي في امريكا ولا يمتلك اي خبره
عسكريه جرادي تم عزله من الفيلق الاجنبي
في اوكرانيا قبل ان يختلس اموال التبرعات
الموجهه
لكانس عقيد امريكي متقاعد اتهمه بتسريب
التكنولوجيا امريكيه زود اوكرانيا بمناظير
ليليه متقدمه ممنوعه من التصدير قبل ان
يؤسس شركه استخدمها في تبييض الاموال جون
ماكينتيرن جندي امريكي سابق تم فصله من
اللفيف الاجنبي
سلم معلومات حساسه الى العدو قبل ان يفر
الى روسيا ويقل من تلفزيونها الرسمي